Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Men are haunted by the vastness of eternity. And so we ask ourselves, will our actions echo across the centuries? It's a great question, worthy of an entire episode of The Rest Is History. But who said it? Napoleon? Abraham Lincoln? Winston Churchill? No, it was Sean Bean, playing Odysseus admittedly in the 2004 film Troy. Not the most obvious casting, I'd have thought. Anyway, Troy
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告干扰音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。人类常为永恒的浩瀚而感到迷惘。因此我们会自问：我们的所作所为能在数百年后激起回响吗？这是一个极好的问题，值得为《The Rest Is History》做一整期节目。但这话是谁说的？拿破仑？亚伯拉罕·林肯？温斯顿·邱吉尔？不，是肖恩·宾，当然了，他是在2004年的电影《特洛伊》中饰演奥德修斯时说的。我想这并不是最显而易见的选角。无论如何，《特洛伊》
is the subject of our discussion today. And with me is the Brixton Achilles, Tom Holland. And after last week's discussion of 1981, this is a bit of an away fixture for me and a home match for Tom. We're on your natural terrain, aren't we? Yes, we are. The fans are gathering in the stands. So the peg for this is the all-conquering Leviathan that is Stephen Fry has a new book out on Troy, which tells you everything you need to know about the fascination with it. But a personal peg for me is that I'm currently reading my son.
就是我们今天讨论的主题。与我同行的则是布里克斯顿的阿喀琉斯——汤姆·霍兰。继上周讨论1981年之后，对我来说这算是一场客场比赛，而对汤姆来说则是主场。我们在你的天然地盘上，对吧？是的，确实如此。粉丝们正在看台聚集。所以，这次讨论的契机是，无所不能的庞然大物史蒂芬·弗莱出了一本关于特洛伊的新书，这说明了人们对这个题材有多么着迷。而对我个人的契机而言，我目前正在给我的儿子
His bedtime reading is a children's version of the Iliad, which he is loving, actually. And I would add that I'm actually right in the middle of writing a sequel to The Trojan War, which is a history of ancient Greece for children in which the gods continue to play lead roles. So you still get Zeus and Athena and everything so coming to a bookshop uh next summer folks so stars are aligned the stars are
读睡前故事，读的是儿童版的《伊利亚特》，他其实非常喜欢。我还想补充的是，我正处于创作《特洛伊战争》续集的关键阶段，这是一部写给儿童的古希腊历史，在书中神明们依然扮演着主角。所以你依然能看到宙斯、雅典娜以及各种神明——各位，明年夏天就会在书店与大家见面了。所以群星璀璨，群星
absolutely but um before we do that before we do that let's uh let's just read some um comments that we've had about uh previous shows and Jamie Kingston got in touch after last week's episode loving this podcast. That's very much the kind of feedback we like. It's already become a favourite of mine. Great. In this episode, I can't remember which one. Oh, this is 1981, of course.
绝对闪耀。但是，在我们开始之前，在开始之前，让我们先读一读大家对之前节目的评论。詹米·金斯顿在上周的节目后联系了我们，说他很喜欢这个podcast。这非常符合我们喜欢的反馈类型。他说：“它已经成了我的最爱。”太棒了。在这期节目中，我不记得是哪一期了。哦，当然，这是关于1981年的那一期。
Yeah, in this episode, we learn that Dominic hates weddings and royal weddings in particular, isn't it? I don't like weddings. Oh, full stop. Okay. Well, I'm just a bit of a misery, you know. Eeyore, somebody said on Twitter. Well, I'm just a bit of a misery, you know. Eeyore, as somebody said on Twitter. Yes, okay.
对，在这期节目中，我们了解到多米尼克讨厌婚礼，尤其是皇家婚礼，对吧？我就是不喜欢婚礼。哦，句号。好吧。嗯，我这人就是有点扫兴，你知道的。埃尤尔（小毛驴），有人在推特上这么说。好吧，我这人就是有点扫兴，你知道的。埃尤尔，正如有人在推特上所说。是的，好吧。
Not wrongly. We learn that Tom wasn't born with a cricket bat in his hand. Again, that's true. And Ian Botham is actually a Victorian. Is he a Victorian or is he more, I think he's more 18th century? Yes, I guess. Yes, probably. He's kind of britches rather than yes you know trousers
说得也没错。我们了解到汤姆出生时手里并没有拿着板球拍。同样，这也是真的。而伊恩·博瑟姆其实是个维多利亚时代的人。他是维多利亚时代的人，还是更偏向于——我觉得他更偏向于18世纪？是的，我猜是的。没错，可能吧。他穿的与其说是裤子，不如说是马裤。
yes yeah and then he's he's also of course uh very 1980s which was the discussion of yeah last week's podcast uh so stewart scott said i'd take 1981 over 2020 at the drop of a hat i guess probably quite a lot of people would agree with that though perhaps not in Toxteth um or indeed in Brixton where I live um one of the principal characters of 1981 was of course a Margaret Thatcher uh who we described as highly divisive I mean I think that's that's kind of written into the that's the rule isn't it you can't mention yeah but Thatcher without saying highly divisive controversial prime minister um and uh this prompted an interesting question from someone who calls himself or herself or itself wrecked on Twitter. And he, she or it asks, can you name the last undivisive prime minister?
是的，对，然后他当然也具有非常浓厚的20世纪80年代色彩，这也是上周播客讨论的内容。所以斯图尔特·斯科特说：“哪怕毫不犹豫，我也宁愿选1981年而不是2020年。”我猜大概有相当多的人会同意这一点，尽管在托克斯特也许不会，或者在我居住的布里克斯顿也不会。1981年的主要人物之一当然是玛格丽特·撒切尔，我们称她为极具分裂性的人物。我的意思是，我觉得这可以说是写进了……这就是条规，对吧？你不能在不提到“极具分裂性的争议性首相”的情况下谈论撒切尔。而这引发了一个有趣的问题，提问者在推特上的名字叫作（或者说昵称是）“Wreck”。
That's a good question. I mean, prime ministers are divisive by their own nature, aren't they? Yes, because to govern is to choose and to choose between two different camps but i suppose some so there are prime ministers who stock in trade is to be emollient aren't there david cameron let's say tony blair before iraq um was harold wilson that divisive was jim callaghan i'm not i'm not convinced they were really and none of the 50s prime ministers were particularly divisive i suppose what's distinctive about mrs s Thatcher is that being divisive was part of her self-image, that she rebelled in it, whereas most prime ministers tend not to.
他、她或它问道：“你们能说出上一位不具分裂性的首相是谁吗？”这是一个好问题。我的意思是，首相按其本质来说就是具有分裂性的，对吧？是的，因为执政就是做出选择，就是在两个不同的阵营之间做出抉择。不过我想有些首相，他们的行事风格就是息事宁人的，对吧？比如戴维·卡梅伦，或者伊拉克战争之前的托尼·布莱尔。哈罗德·威尔逊算吗？吉姆·卡拉汉算吗？我并不确信他们真的是这样，而且20世纪50年代的首相们也没有哪个特别具有分裂性的。我想，撒切尔夫人与众不同之处在于，具有分裂性构成了她自我形象的一部分，她以此为乐，而大多数首相往往不会这样。
Exactly. She thought if you were not being divisive, that showed you weren't, you weren't, you had no guts. You weren't in the arena. Tories talk about being one nation, conservatives, don't they? They do. And they always, and they don't they? They do. Which basically... And they always, and they bash Labour politicians. They say they're class warriors. They're fomenting class war and all this kind of thing. So they sort of, part of the Tory message is often to say
没错。她认为如果你不具备分裂性，那就说明你没有胆识，你没有勇气。你根本没有踏入竞技场。保守党人谈论自己代表整个国家，也就是“一个国家”的保守党，对吧？他们的确这样。而且他们总是……难道不是吗？他们确实如此。这基本上……而且他们总是猛烈抨击工党政客。他们说工党政客是阶级斗争的煽动者，说他们在煽动阶级战争之类的话。所以他们的部分保守党信息往往是在宣称
there is no division, actually, and we should all just be one happy family. And vote Tory. Yeah, sort of Stanley Baldwin. Yes, yeah. Okay, well, that's, I knew you'd have good answer for that. Anyway, let's, I think that's enough of modern history. Can we get to a far more interesting topic?
实际上根本没有分裂，我们本该是一个幸福快乐的大家庭。然后投票给保守党。对，有点像斯坦利·鲍德温。是的，没错。好吧，我就知道你会给出不错的回答。无论如何，我想现代史就聊到这里吧。我们能谈谈一个更有趣的话题吗？
Namely, the Bronze Age. Great, yes. So, looking at the publicity for Stephen Fry's new book, there's one line in particular, enter the world of Troy and the most legendary story ever told. Well, is it the most legendary story ever told? I suppose it is, Tom O'Lan. That's quite a claim, isn't it? But tell us, okay, so for the modernists among us, tell us in no more than about 40 words, the entire story of the Trojan War. Okay, the world's most beautiful woman, the daughter of Zeus, Helen, is abducted by a
也就是青铜时代。太好了，是的。所以，看看史蒂芬·弗莱新书的宣传语，其中有一句格外引人注目：“走进特洛伊的世界，聆听史上最传奇的故事。”好吧，这真的是史上最传奇的故事吗？我想是的，汤姆·霍兰。这口气可不小，对吧？不过给我们讲讲吧，对于我们这些现代人来说，请用不超过40字左右的篇幅，讲完特洛伊战争的整个故事。好的。世界上最美丽的女人、宙斯的女儿海伦，被一个名叫
Trojan prince called Paris to the city of Troy. All the Greeks have sworn an oath that if Helen gets stolen by anyone, they will go and get her back. So the heroes of Greece are kind of duty bound to sail to Troy. They camp in front of the walls of Troy for 10 years. Terrible and heroic deeds are done. Great heroes fight, great heroes die. At the end, the only way that the Greeks can get into Troy is to play a trick. They build a huge wooden horse. They leave it, supposedly, as an offering to Poseidon, the god of the sea. In fact, the Greeks have hidden their best warriors inside the belly of the horse. The Trojans rather stupidly take the horse inside Troy. The Greeks come out, they burn Troy, they all go home. Great. Wow, Tom, you're
帕里斯的特洛伊王子拐到了特洛伊城。所有的希腊人都曾发誓，如果海伦被任何人劫走，他们就会去把她夺回来。因此，希腊的英雄们可以说是责无旁贷地乘船驶向特洛伊。他们在特洛伊城墙前驻扎了10年。惨烈与英勇的事迹不断上演。伟大的英雄们战斗，伟大的英雄们死去。最后，希腊人进入特洛伊的唯一方法就是使用诡计。他们建造了一匹巨大的木马。他们留下了这匹木马，据说是作为对海神波塞冬的献祭。事实上，希腊人把他们最勇猛的战士藏在了马腹之中。特洛伊人相当愚蠢地把木马拉进了特洛伊城内。希腊人钻了出来，烧毁了特洛伊，然后各自回家了。太棒了。哇，汤姆，你
very good at these little summaries, I think. If the history doesn't work out, you can always... So this is the question,'t it did it actually happen and give us a year pin yourself down to a year or at least a century well greek historians gave various dates and they would range by our dating system for kind of um 1250 to 1150 bc um so yeah that's it that that's the end of the bronze Age. And the huge question is, when the Greeks wrote about the Trojan War, and I suppose specifically Homer, who's the great poet, who everybody else who writes about the Trojan War stands in his shadow, were they drawing on authentic memories of something that actually happened?
非常擅长做这种简短的总结，我想如果历史这条路走不通，你总可以……所以问题就在于：这真的发生过吗？给我们一个确切的年份，把它限定在某一年，或者至少是某一个世纪。好吧，希腊历史学家们给出了各种各样的日期，按照我们的纪年系统，大约从公元前1250年跨越到公元前1150年。所以，是的，这就是青铜时代的终结。而巨大的问题在于，当希腊人书写特洛伊战争时，我想尤其是荷马这位伟人——所有其他书写特洛伊战争的人都生活在他的阴影之下——他们是在汲取真实发生过的事情的真实记忆吗？
And there have been various opinions about that over the course of time. The Greeks and the Romans were fairly convinced that it had happened. They gave various accounts of it, various versions of it. There was no kind of definitive version, although Homer was kind of as close to as definitive as they got. By the 18th, by the beginning of the 19th century, people were coming to assume that it was a fairy tale, that it had no roots in fact at all. And then the German businessman turned archaeologist Heinrich Schliemann famously decided that he was going to prove it had happened. And using Homer, he went to what's now kind of the north of Turkey.
随着时间的推移，人们对此产生了各种各样的看法。希腊人和罗马人相当确信这件事确实发生过。他们对此有各种各样的叙述和版本。虽然没有哪一个可以被称为绝对的最终版本，但荷马的版本已经相当接近他们心中的定论了。到了18世纪末、19世纪初，人们开始认为这只是一个童话故事，在现实中根本没有任何根基。随后，由德国商人转型为考古学家的海因里希·施里曼（Heinrich Schliemann）做出了一个著名的决定：他要证明这件事确实发生过。借助荷马史诗的指引，他来到了如今土耳其北部的地方。
Yeah, so where are we? Let me interrupt you, Tom. Where are we exactly? Is this a sort of roundabout Gallipoli? Am I right? Yeah, so it's by Gallipoli. So you think of the Aegean separating Greece and what's now Turkey. You think of the narrow strip of water
是的，那么我们现在在哪里？打断你一下，汤姆。我们到底在哪里？这地方有点像加里波利半岛附近吗？我没记错吧？是的，就在加里波利附近。你可以想象一下爱琴海将希腊与如今的土耳其隔开。你可以想想那条狭窄的水域，
that separates Europe from Asia and leads into the Black Sea. Troy commands the entrance to those straits. So you can see that it's strategically significant. Schumann goes there, he digs it up, supposedly. I mean, and when we say dig it up, I mean, he really digs it up. He digs a massive great trench and demolishes vast swathes of the archaeology and discovers what he claims to have been Homer's Troy. And I guess
它将欧洲与亚洲分隔开来，并通往黑海。特洛伊扼守着这些海峡的入口。所以你可以看出它在战略上具有重要意义。施里曼去了那里，把它给挖了出来，可以说是吧。我的意思是，当我们说把它挖出来时，他是真的在挖。他挖了一条巨大的战沟，摧毁了大片的考古遗址，并发现了自称是荷马笔下的特洛伊。我想
the consensus of archaeologists now would be that this is the site, it's a hill called Hisilic, that this probably was Troy. And we know that this is where the Greeks and the Romans thought the battle had been fought, because in the wake of Alexander's conquest, a town grows up there, which is a kind of homage to the original Troy. Well, they definitely thought it happened, didn't they? Because I've just been writing a children's book about Alexander the Great, and there's a great moment in it when they pitch up the Macedonians, they're invading Persia, and Alexander makes a special trip to Troy to what he thinks is the tomb of Achilles. And he does what we all do when we visit the graves of our ancestors. He takes all his clothes off, anoints himself in oil, and then runs round and round.
如今考古学家的共识会认为这就是那个遗址，那是一座名叫希萨立克（Hisilic）的小山丘，这里很可能就是特洛伊。我们知道这就是希腊人和罗马人认为爆发过战役的地方，因为在亚历山大征服之后，那里兴起了一座城镇，某种程度上它是对最初特洛伊的一种致敬。好吧，他们绝对认为这件事发生过，对吧？因为我刚刚写了一本关于亚历山大的儿童读物，里面有一个很棒的片段：马其顿人兵临城下，他们正在入侵波斯，而亚历山大特意去了特洛伊，来到了他认为是阿喀琉斯之墓的地方。他做了我们所有人去凭吊祖先墓地时都会做的事：他脱光了衣服，在身上抹满橄榄油，然后绕着墓地一圈又一圈地奔跑。
Yeah, it's classic behaviour on a Turkish trip. We've all done it. Yeah. Yeah. And before that, when, so Alexander says that he is invading Asia to get revenge for the Persians who had invaded Greece back in 490 and 480 BC. And that had been led by Xerxes, the king of Persia. And Xerxes, when he led his invasion, he went to the site of Troy and paid his respects to the heroes. I mean, this was kind of good PR. Yeah. And this sense that the Trojan War is a kind of decisive moment in an ongoing war between East and West, between Asia and Europe,
是的，这是去土耳其旅行时的经典行径。我们都干过。是的。而且在此之前，当——所以亚历山大声称他入侵亚洲是为了替公元前490年和480年入侵希腊的波斯人复仇。那次入侵是由波斯国王薛西斯领导的。薛西斯在领导入侵时，曾去过特洛伊遗址，并向英雄们致敬。我的意思是，这算是一种很好的公关。是的。并且，特洛伊战争是东西方之间、亚洲与欧洲之间一场持续战争中的决定性时刻这种感觉，
is very much a theme that the Greeks pick up on. And it's elaborated by Herodotus, who is the first great historian. Translated by me, folks, again, rush out and buy. Oh, very good plug. Yeah, just getting that, slipping that one in. Quality plug. So Herodotus rationalises the abduction of Helen as basically being something not very important. And his take is that the Greeks massively overreact. I mean, Herodotus basically says,
正是希腊人极力宣扬的主题。而第一位伟大的历史学家希罗多德也对此进行了详细阐述。各位，这也是由我翻译的，赶快去买吧。哦，非常棒的软广。是的，顺便提一下，巧妙地塞进去了。高质量的广告。所以希罗多德把海伦被劫持一事合理化了，认为这基本上算不上一件多重要的事情。他的看法是希腊人反应过度了。我的意思是，希罗多德基本上说，
we've all stolen a princess or two. I mean, it's ridiculous to overreact. So it's almost like a bit sort of a false flag operation or something. I think Herodotus, you know, he begins his history. So this is the first passage of prose of any work of history ever written. And it's about how people in Asia and people in Greece are constantly stealing each other's princesses. And he really thought this happened. Yeah, he thinks it happened. He thinks it happened. And also, interestingly, Thucydides, who is the next great historian who follows after Herodotus, who's famously sceptical.
我们大家谁没偷过一两个公主呢。我的意思是，反应过度未免太可笑了。所以这感觉几乎有点像某种“假旗行动”（自导自演）之类的。我觉得希罗多德，你知道的，他的历史著作是以这个开篇的。所以这也是有史以来任何历史著作中的第一段散文。内容是关于亚洲人和希腊人如何不断地互相偷对方的公主。他是真的觉得这事发生过。对，他觉得这发生了。他觉得这发生了。而且有趣的是，继希罗多德之后的下一位伟大家喻户晓的历史学家修昔底德，他以怀疑论著称，
He also thinks it happens, but he provides the kind of rationalist perspective on it. And he says that he doesn't think that it was about Helen at all he thinks that it was about um it was about uh wealth and that Agamemnon who is the um the the the leading king the king of Mycenae the richest city uh and who was kind of commander-in-chief at Troy that he was so powerful that he could get all the various Greek kings together and lead a common expedition. And Thucydides thinks this is all about kind of controlling trade routes and stuff. Oh my God, he's a Marxist. He thinks it's all about the search for profit. He's a kind of very, his perspective is very much that of a strategist, someone who doesn't have much place for fantastical tales of abducted princesses. And I guess that that's probably the perspective that many modern
他也认为这件事发生了，但他提供了一种唯理主义的视角。他说他认为这根本不是为了海伦，他认为这关乎……这关乎财富。阿伽门农作为主要的国王、迈锡尼（最富有的城市）的国王，同时也是特洛伊之战的最高统帅，他是如此强大，以至于能把各个希腊国王聚集在一起并领导一场共同的远征。修昔底德认为这整件事全是为了控制贸易路线之类的事情。天哪，他是个马克思主义者。他认为这纯粹是为了追求利益。他的视角非常像一个战略家，一个对被劫持公主的奇幻故事不屑一顾的人。我想这也是许多现代
historians would have as well, that this is a war that's happening in the context of great power politics and attempts to control trade routes and things like that. It's not about beautiful princesses being abducted. Of course. So the temptation is to see it as Europe versus Asia, isn't it? But my sense is that that would be completely wrong, because isn't this just generally the Greek-speaking world? Isn't Troy... I mean, what would Troy have been? Would it have been a Greek-speaking city, a Hittite city? So the Hittites are the people in Anatolia, aren't they? Right. I mean, what is it? Yeah, so the Hittites are a key part of trying to understand
历史学家可能持有的视角，即这场大国政治背景下的战争是为了试图控制贸易路线等事情，而不是为了争夺被劫持的美丽公主。当然。所以人们很容易把它看作是欧洲对阵亚洲，对吧？但我的直觉是，这种看法完全是错误的，因为这难道不普遍只是讲希腊语的世界吗？特洛伊难道……我的意思是，特洛伊究竟是什么？它是一座说希腊语的城市，还是一座赫梯城市？所以赫梯人是安纳托利亚当地的人，对吧？没错。我的意思是，这到底是什么？是的，所以赫梯人是试图理解
what the actual Trojan War might have been. And the Hittites rule an empire across what's now Turkey, Anatolia. And at the beginning of the 20th century, a kind of cache of royal correspondence was found. And so over the course of the 20th century, a kind of cache of royal correspondence was found. And so over the course of the 20th century, these have been deciphered. And there are a couple of letters that cast potential light on the Trojan War. So one of them mentions a town called Wilusa. And sounds just like Troy.
真正的特洛伊战争可能是什么样的关键所在。赫梯人在如今的土耳其和安纳托利亚全境建立了一个庞大的帝国。在20世纪初，人们发现了一批皇家信件档案。因此在整个20世纪期间，这些信件得到了破译。其中有几封信可能对了解特洛伊战争有所启发。其中一封信提到了一个名叫维鲁萨（Wilusa）的城镇。听起来简直就像特洛伊。
Well, but another name for Troy was Ilium. So you can see that there's potentially a kind of bleed there from Wilusa, perhaps, to Ilium. And what's also interesting is that the king of Wilusa is a man called Alexandu. And an alternative name for Paris, the prince who abducts Helen, is Alexander. So, you know, maybe there's a mesh there.
不过，特洛伊的另一个名字是伊利昂（Ilium）。所以你可以看出，从维鲁萨到伊利昂之间可能存在某种词音上的演变。同样有趣的是，维鲁萨的国王是一个名叫亚历山杜（Alexandu）的人。而劫走海伦的特洛伊王子帕里斯的另一个名字正是亚历山大。所以，你知道的，这其中也许存在某种契合。
And the other letter is a letter addressed to the king of a land called Akiwawa. Gosh, you said that very nicely. My Hittite is fluent. And Akiwawa sounds, sounds again a bit like Akea and Achaeans is what Homer writing in perhaps the second half of the 8th century BC calls the Greeks so perhaps the Achaeans the Akeoi which Homer is using is a trace element of Akiwawa but the the key thing about this is that nobody really would care about this very obscure kind of bronze age diplomacy war whatever were it not for the fact that homer had written this amazing poetry yeah and that that poetry has then kind of descended down through the century so
另一封信是写给一个名叫阿基瓦瓦（Akiwawa）的土地的国王的。天哪，你读得太好听了。我的赫梯语非常流利。而“阿基瓦瓦”听起来，听起来又有点像“阿科亚”（Akea），而生活在大约公元前8世纪下半叶的荷马用来称呼希腊人的词正是“阿凯亚人”（Achaeans）。所以，也许荷马所使用的“阿凯亚人”（Akeoi）正是“阿基瓦瓦”留下的蛛丝马迹。但关键在于，如果不是因为荷马写下了如此惊艳的诗篇，根本没有人会关心这种晦涩难懂的青铜时代外交战或别的什么。
your your son you know you're reading it to your son yeah what. What is it about the Trojan War? Presumably, I mean, he's not interested in, you know, trade routes through the Hellespont. No, he loves the Hittites. He's really into the Hittites. No, you're right. I think it's the, what is it? That's a very good question.
所以你的儿子，你知道的，你正在给他读这个。特洛伊战争究竟有什么魅力？据我推测，他肯定对……黑海海峡的贸易路线不感兴趣吧？不，他热爱赫梯人。他超级迷恋赫梯人。不，你说得对。我觉得是……这到底是什么？这是一个很好的问题。
I think, I mean, obviously with the Iliad, it's the personalities, isn't it? And it's the slightly unexpected, I mean, to a modern sensibility, it's a very unexpected story. So Achilles, the great hero, spends half the time sulking in his tent and refusing to come out. There's a sort of incongruity. There's this odd disconnect between the sort of heroic status of the characters. And often they're quite to modernise Weasley behaviour, which I think is intriguing. Yeah, I mean, also, I mean, an interesting thing about it is that if you look at the Iliad, which is Homer's account of the Trojan War, there's not actually very much
我想，显然对于《伊利亚特》来说，吸引人的是个性，对吧？而且是一种略带意外的特质——以现代人的审美来看，这是一个非常出人意料的故事。比如伟大的英雄阿喀琉斯，有一半时间都在自己的帐篷里生闷气，拒绝出来。这种人设有些不够合拍。这些角色的英雄气概与他们时常表现出的、以现代标准来看相当小家子气的行为之间，存在着一种奇怪的脱节，我觉得这非常耐人寻味。是的，我的意思是，还有一个有趣的地方在于，如果你看看荷马对特洛伊战争的记述《伊利亚特》，里面其实并没有太多关于特洛伊战争本身的内容。它所涵盖的时间非常短。所以许多最著名的桥段，比如特洛伊木马，其实并不在《伊利亚特》里。
about the Trojan War there. It's a very short space of time. So lots of the most famous things, like the Trojan horse, the Trojan horse is not in the Iliad. like the trojan horse the trojan horse isn't in the it's not in the iliad and the trojan horse is a great story isn't it i mean the trojan horse is this i mean clearly this sort of uh this you know this this mythic sort of this dissection of of hubris this moment of great craftiness this sort of plot by the greeks this sort of heist effectively that comes off well you i mean it always seemed to me a ridiculous plot. You're Trojans. You've been suffering a war, a siege for 10 years. The Greeks go, and there's a huge, great horse. You're going to have a bit of suspicion, aren't you?
比如特洛伊木马，它并不在《伊利亚特》里，特洛伊木马根本不在其中。特洛伊木马是个很棒的故事，对吧？我的意思是，特洛伊木马这个——显然这种神话般的、对傲慢的剖析、这个充满大智慧的时刻、希腊人的这种阴谋、实际上是一次成功的惊天劫掠——好吧，在我看来这总是一个荒谬的阴谋。你们是特洛伊人。你们已经忍受了一场长达10年的围城战。希腊人撤了，留下一匹巨大的木马。你们难道不会起疑心吗？
Are you? I mean, you know, there's actually a wooden horse at the site of ancient Troy. So the Turkish authorities have built a wooden horse and it sits there outside their site. It doesn't look great, to be honest. It's not terribly impressive. How many do you think it would fit in? Seven? I don't know, ten? That would be enough, wouldn't it? But they just needed to open the gates, right?
会吗？我的意思是，在古代特洛伊的遗址上其实真的有一匹木马。土耳其当局建造了一匹木马，它就安放在遗址外面。老实说，它看起来不怎么好。并不是特别令人印象深刻。你觉得里面能塞进去多少人？七个？我不知道，十个？那就够了，对吧？但他们只需要打开城门就行了，对不对？
They don't need to storm the whole city. Don't they just get in and open the gates? Isn't that how it works? Yeah, they open the gates, but there are enough of them to start the slaughtering and the pillaging. I mean, you wouldn't do that with seven people, would you? No, you need more than that. It's got to be quite a big horse.
他们不需要强攻整座城。他们不就是潜进去然后打开城门吗？事情难道不是这样的吗？是的，他们打开城门，但里面得有足够多的人来发起屠杀和掠夺。我的意思是，你不可能只凭七个人就做到这一点，对吧？不，你需要比这更多的人。这必须是一匹相当大的木马。
Listen, let's take some questions, because questions about the Trojan War have a very, very long pedigree. The Emperor Tiberius, when he was retired on Capri, used to hold the equivalent of a pub quiz um for his about the trojan war yeah but and he would ask some kind of difficult questions like um uh so achilles the great hero when he was a boy uh was disguised as a girl and tiberius would say um what what name did achilles have as a girl and odysseus the uh the cunning hero who um comes up with the idea of the trojan War, he has a very, very long voyage back home.
听着，我们来回答一些问题，因为关于特洛伊战争的问题有着非常非常悠久的历史渊源。罗马皇帝提比略在卡普里岛退休期间，曾为他的宾客举办过相当于现代酒吧问答测验的活动，考题就是关于特洛伊战争的。并且他会出一些相当棘手的问题，比如：伟大的英雄阿喀琉斯在还是个男孩的时候曾被伪装成女孩，提比略就会问，“阿喀琉斯作为女孩时叫什么名字？”而奥德修斯——那位想出特洛伊木马计谋的聪慧英雄，他在回家的路上经历了一段非常非常漫长的航程。
And he sails past sinister creatures called the Sirens who sing beautifully and then devour the sailors who are lured to their island. And Tiberius wanted to know what the song was that the Sirens sung. And he would expect people to know this would they know it well he would and um there was one of his guests who cheated and um got hold of the questions before they were asked so what do you think tiberius did to him threw him off the rock had him killed don't don't cheat if you go to a pub quiz run by a seizure anyway let's come back to at the questions that we've been asked um but tom i think we should take a break first um okay well listen before we take the break i'm going to read you carl johans or johans question and we can have a you can have a ponder because i'm going to put you we have to answer this what war or event he asks comes closest to being of similar significance to the modern west
他航行经过了一些名为塞壬（海妖）的险恶生物，她们歌声优美，然后会吞食那些被诱惑到她们岛上的水手。提比略想知道塞壬唱的歌究竟是什么。他会期望人们知道答案吗？他们会知道吗？好吧，他的确这么想。结果他的一个客人作弊了，在问题提出之前就弄到了答案。所以你们觉得提比略对那个人做了什么？把他从悬崖上扔下去？把他处决了？如果你去参加由恺撒举办的酒吧问答，千万别作弊。总之，让我们回到大家提过的问题上。不过汤姆，我觉得我们应该先休息一下。好吧，听着，在休息之前，我要读一下卡尔·约翰（Carl Johan）的问题，你可以琢磨一下，因为我要抛给你……我们必须回答这个问题：他问，在现代西方人眼中，哪场战争或事件最接近于特洛伊战争对古希腊人的重要意义？
as troy was to the gree Good question. Let's have a break. launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back everybody to the rest is history so just before the break uh tom asked me carl johan's question which is what war comes close to being of similar significance to the modern West as Troy was to the Greeks? So it seems to me, Tom, that the obvious answer to that is, I mean, the blatantly obvious answer is World War II. I mean, World War II is the event that sort of lingers in the Western psyche as the ultimate symbol of man's humanity to man. It's the ultimate morality tale. We structure the way we think about the world around the evil of the Nazis,
好问题。我们先休息一下。我们推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想收听无广告的音频、加更节目并优先购买现场活动门票，请访问 the rest is entertainment.com，网址是 the rest is entertainment.com。欢迎各位回到《The Rest Is History》。在休息之前，汤姆问了我卡尔·约翰的问题：哪场战争在现代西方人眼中的重要意义最接近于特洛伊战争对古希腊人的意义？在看来，汤姆，最显而易见的答案是——也就是显而易见的答案——第二次世界大战。我的意思是，二战是在西方心理中挥之不去、作为人类对同类之残暴终极象征的事件。它是终极的道德故事。我们围绕着纳粹的邪恶、挺身对抗他们的英雄主义、绥靖政策的危害等方方面面来构建我们看待世界的方式。你不觉得第二次世界大战基本上就是我们的特洛伊战争、我们的神话故事吗？我认为在神话层面上是这样的，但我认为其中也融入了一点第一次世界大战的色彩，因为特洛伊战争的一个特点在于，它是毫无意义的。
the heroism of standing up to them, the dangers of appeasement, all that kind of stuff. Don't you think that the Second World War is basically our Trojan War, our mythic story? I think on the level of myth, but I think there's also a seasoning of the First World War because the thing about the Trojan War is that it's pointless.
所以如果你想想一战的色彩，特洛伊战争的一个特点就在于它是毫无意义的。因此如果你认为一战的神话在于：这一切究竟是为了什么？这一切都是徒劳无功的。人们在泥泞中互相屠杀。泥泞、鲜血与废话。这基本上就是特洛伊战争的写照。我的意思是，它是毁灭性的、破坏性的，而且并没有真正带来什么成果。等等，希腊人可不是这么想的，对吧？他们难道不觉得这很英雄主义、很鼓舞人心吗？当亚历山大赤身裸体地绕着阿喀琉斯的陵墓奔跑时，
So if you think of the seasoning of the First World War, because the thing about the Trojan War is that it's pointless. So if you think of the myth of the First World War is that it's, you know, what was it all for? It was all fought in vain. People slaughtering each other in mud. Mud, blood and poppycock. That's pretty much what the Trojan War is. I mean, it's ruinous and it's destructive and nothing really comes of it. But hold on, the Greeks didn't think about it that way, didn't they? Didn't they find it heroic and inspiring? I mean, when Alexander runs around the tomb of Achilles
他可没在想……他可没在想“这完全是在浪费时间，这简直是青铜时代的道格拉斯·黑格”。好吧，阿喀琉斯之所以成为伟大的英雄，是因为他选择了一个短暂但名垂青史的人生，而不是一个漫长却默默无闻的人生。所以他就像鲁珀特·布鲁克（Rupert Brooke）之流。是的，但在续集《奥德赛》中，我们在冥界遇到了阿喀琉斯的鬼魂，他说这太糟糕了。哦，真的吗？
naked, he's not thinking, you know, he's not thinking, oh, this was a complete waste of time and this is the sort of Douglas Haig of the Bronze Age. Well, Achilles becomes a great hero because he chooses a short life and eternal fame over a long life and obscurity. So he's like Rupert Brooke or something. Yeah, but in the sequel, The Odyssey, we meet the ghost of Achilles in the underworld and he says it's terrible. Oh, really? You know, I made a terrible mistake.
你知道的，“我犯了一个巨大的错误。我宁愿当一个在土地上劳作的奴隶，也不愿在冥界当个国王。”哦，真的吗？是的，而且我认为，如果你看看古希腊悲剧作家，雅典的悲剧作家，埃斯库罗斯曾说过，基本上古希腊悲剧完全就是对特洛伊战争的一种演绎——将其视为一种痛苦的毫无意义的事件。我认为，如果你将第一次世界大战与第二次世界大战融合在一起，两者的混合体就会产生某种与之非常接近的东西。现在，制作人在你说话的时候一直在用问题纠缠我——倒不是说他没在听你说话，汤姆，而是他一直在给我发短信询问关于特洛伊的海伦的问题。这真的只是一场为争夺一个美女而爆发的战争吗？给我们讲讲这个女人吧，诸如此类的问题。所以，是的，这很有趣，对吧？整件事都围绕着一个女人。我的意思是，现实中由女性挑起、或者像这样以女性为绝对核心的真实战争其实并不多吧？好吧，我认为，再次回到希罗多德的话题，他的历史著作就是从不同的人互相强暴、强暴彼此的女性这一记述开始的。而且我认为，在令人不安的程度上，有一种观念认为战争的历史同时也是强暴的历史。所以在某种程度上，海伦被劫持的故事背后确实有着某种黑暗的真相。但是，（在更浪漫的意义上），我们确实收到了一个非常棒的
I'd much rather be a kind of slave working the land than be a king in the underworld. Oh, really? Yeah, and I think, you know, and if you look at the Greek tragedians, the Athenian tragedians, and Aeschylus, one of them said that, you know, basically Greek tragedy absolutely a kind of riff on the idea of the trojan war as being kind of agonizingly pointless and i think i think that you know if you so if you fuse the first world war with the second world war the mix of that would give you something approximating it now the producer has been pestering me with questions while you've
来自朱利安·伦诺克斯（Julian Lennox）的问题，他说：“说到海伦，历史上还有哪些著名的大美人？具体来说，是那些美貌具有历史意义、能够改变历史走向的人。所以，你知道的，有没有哪些女性，她们的美貌足以改变历史的进程？你们怎么看？”
been talking, not that he wasn't listening to you, Tom, but he's just been texting me with questions about Helen of Troy. Was this just a fight about a beautiful woman? Tell us about the woman, all this kind of stuff. So yes, that's interesting, isn't it? That it's all about a woman. I mean, there aren't many real wars that are either generated by women or that have women at their sort of absolute centre as this does? Well, I think, again, to go back to Herodotus, the history begins with an account of different people raping each other, raping each other's women. And I think there is a kind of, to a disturbing degree, there is a sense that the history of war is also the history of rape. So to that extent, there is a kind of, you know, a dark truth to the story of Helen's abduction. But, you know, in the kind of the more romantic sense of it, we do actually have a very good
我觉得这是一个很好的问题。汤姆，他其实说的是“人”（people），并没有特指女性。对，他说了。我刚才表现得很性别歧视。你暴露了自己令人震惊的一面，那是男性凝视在起作用。这真是一个可怕的时刻，我觉得你离被全网取消资格肯定只有一步之遥了。所以，我不知道，这是一个有趣的问题：到底是女性，还是性感？
question from Julian Lennox, who says, speaking of Helen, who are other historically beautiful people, specifically people whose beauty had historical significance, as in it changed the course of history. So, you know, do we have, are there women whose beauty was such that it changed the course of history? What do you think?
因为性感显然确实很重要，我总是能想到的例子就是安妮·博林。哦，好极了，是的。所以安妮·博林有趣的地方在于，她并不属于传统意义上有吸引力的人。当时的人，比如都铎王朝宫廷里的所有这些大使都会写信回报说，哦，她面色菜黄，长得像狐狸一样狡猾，你知道的，她并没有吸引力。她有十一根手指，对吧？但她……关于她的手指也有这种说法。
I think that's a great question. He actually said people, Tommy, he didn't say women. Yeah, he did. I'm being sexist there. You've revealed your own shocking, that's the male gaze in action. this is a terrible moment i think your cancellation is surely only moments away um so i don't it's an interesting one is it women or is it sexiness
我想我们大概应该……对，把这个轻描淡写地带过。这难道就是关键吗？是的，也许是的。也许她能够非常巧妙地利用这些多出来的手指？谁知道呢？不知道。所以安妮·博林对亨利八世有着极大的掌控力，很显然，国王对她着迷不已。
because sexiness obviously does matter and the example i always think of is amberlynn oh good yes so the funny thing about amberlynn is she's not conventionally attractive people at the time like all these sort of ambassadors at the Tudor court would write back and they would say, oh, she's sallow-faced, she's sort of vulpine, you know, she's not attractive. She had 11 fingers, didn't she? But she... There's this claim about the finger as well.
如果不是因为这一点——因为她对那种崭新的福音派思想、对批评天主教教会的新兴思想感兴趣——完全合乎情理的是，英国……新教运动或许依然会出现，但国王会将其压制下去，英国本会像法国那样继续保持一个天主教国家。所以你可以说，对于安妮·博林这样的人来说，某个个人的性魅力确实掌握着巨大结构性、文化性变革的钥匙。所以她就是那张“引发了一千座修道院被解散”的脸。
I think we should probably, yeah, gloss over that. Was that the key? Yeah, maybe it was. Maybe she was able to put these extra fingers to very potent use. Who knows? Don't know. So Anne Boleyn has this hold over Henry VIII, clearly, and he's obsessed with her.
一千本圣经。一千本圣经。那克利奥帕特拉（埃及艳后）呢？克利奥帕特拉其实并不是非常……好吧，是的。我的意思是，克利奥帕特拉当然一直被认为拥有倾国倾城的美貌。但其实并不漂亮，对吧？好吧，如果你看她的硬币，她看起来并不是特别漂亮。而且我认为，美色未必是
And had it not been for that, by the fact that she was interested in the kind of new evangelical ideas the new kind of ideas critical of catholic church it is perfectly plausible that england you know there would have been a protestant movement but the king would have fought it off and that england would remain a catholic country as france did so you could you can say with somebody like anne boleyn one, one individual's sexual allure does hold the key to a massive structural cultural change. So she's the face that launched a thousand monasteries being dissolved.
她用来吸引那些与她同床共枕的男人的筹码。因为基本上我们只知道她和两个男人睡过，那就是尤利乌斯·凯撒（儒略·恺撒）和马克·安东尼。而这两个男人碰巧都是当时地中海最有权势的男人。所以我想我们可以——甚至当安东尼死后，克利奥帕特拉又去对屋大维（即未来的奥古斯都）抛媚眼。所以如果梅拉尼娅·特朗普转投乔·拜登的怀抱，我们就会知道她看中唐纳德可不是因为他的长相。是的，我想这是一个合理的推测。
A thousand Bibles. A thousand Bibles. What about Cleopatra? Cleopatra's not very... Well, yes. I mean, Cleopatra is, of course, is always presumed to have been incredibly beautiful. But not beautiful, right? Well, if you look at her coins, she doesn't look particularly beautiful. And I think that sex wasn't necessarily
但当然，在将克利奥帕特拉描绘成某种致命的诱惑者的过程中，多多少少有海伦的影子——也就是那种美丽女人的爱会给英雄甚至城市带来毁灭的想法。所以，是的，这绝对是其中的一部分。现在，我们还有许多更多的问题，对吧？再给我来一个问题。
what she was offering the men she slept with. Because basically we only know that she slept with two men, Julius Caesar and Mark Antony. And both of those men happened to be the most powerful men in the Mediterranean at the time. So I think we can, and even when Antony dies, Cleopatra then makes a pitch at Octavian, who will, the future Augustus. So if Melania Trump moves on to Joe Biden, we'll know that she wasn't interested in Donald for his looks. Yes, I think that that would be a reasonable presumption.
乔希·哈罗德·威尔逊（Josh Harold Wilson）提问——我不知道这和哈罗德·威尔逊有没有亲戚关系。但乔希·哈罗德·威尔逊问：“电影是探索历史的有用工具，还是说它带来的危害大于益处？”好吧，这和《王冠》这部剧非常契合，对吧？那么关于特洛伊的电影，你看过布拉德·皮特主演的那部特洛伊电影吗？
But of course, in the way that Cleopatra is portrayed as a kind of fatal seductress, there is something there of Helen, the idea that the love of a beautiful woman can be destructive for heroes and indeed for cities. So yeah, that's absolutely part of it. Now, do we have, we have lots more questions, don't we? Give me another question.
那是关于古代世界最烂的电影。这口气可真大。比《克利奥帕特拉》还烂？《克利奥帕特拉》挺伟大的。不过太长了。我记得非常无聊。不，不，不。《特洛伊》是有史以来最烂的电影，因为它把神明给删掉了。
What about Josh Harold Wilson? I wonder if there's any relation. But Josh Harold Wilson says, is film a useful tool for exploring history or does it do more damage than good? Well, that's very topical with The Crown, isn't it? So the film of Troy, you've seen the film of Troy, their Brad Pitt film?
因此它删掉了所有让荷马引人入胜的元素，因为没有了神明，它就变得相当乏味。不仅如此，他们拍摄《特洛伊》时试图使其具有历史根基，而问题的关键在于，无论你如何看待孕育出特洛伊神话这棵参天大树的微小事实橡子——它根本没有发生过。事情并非像荷马所描绘的那样发生，没有海伦，也没有特洛伊木马，一切都只是神话。所以，试图将其描绘成真实发生过的这种做法，本身就是对精力和心血的一种惊人浪费。它真的是烂透了。但它会带来什么危害吗？我不觉得，我觉得它不会造成什么危害。可能吧，好吧，你可以辩称——会造成危害吗？我不觉得。我觉得它不会造成什么危害。可能吧，好吧，你可以辩称，
It's the worst film about the ancient world ever made. That's a big claim. Worse than Cleopatra? Cleopatra's great. It's very long, though. Very boring, as I remember. No, no, no. Troy is the worst film ever made because it gets rid of the gods.
作为宣传工具的电影确实会带来危害，对吧？我的意思是，它们进入了人们的集体想象之中，如果它们宣扬的是分歧、仇恨之类的情绪的话。好吧，一个有趣的对比是《斯巴达300勇士》，这也是一部关于古希腊的电影，讲述了斯巴达人在温泉关的故事。是的。
And therefore it gets rid of everything that makes Homer interesting because without the gods it becomes quite dull and more than that what they're trying to do with Troy is to make it historically grounded and the whole point is that that whatever you may think about the kind of the the the tiny acorn of fact that gives rise to the great oak of of the trojan myth it didn't happen it didn't happen as homer portrays it there was no there was no helen there was no trojan horse so it's all myth so the very attempt to try and portray it as it did is is a spectacular waste of energy and effort it's it's truly terrible but does it do any uh any harm i don't think so i don't think it does any damage probably well i suppose you can argue it do any harm? I don't think so. I don't think it does any damage. Probably, well, I suppose you can argue
我认为那是一部对古代世界的绝妙描绘，因为它非常准确地将斯巴达人描绘成原始纳粹、原始法西斯，而这基本上就是他们的本质。斯巴达人曾给纳粹提供过巨大的灵感。而《300勇士》令人不安的地方在于，它并没有迎合我们所期望的那种道德观念：强者恒强，弱者恒弱，而弱者因弱小而遭人鄙视。这让人感到非常不安，但我也觉得它极其极其准确。不过，这也是有原因的，你知道的，《300勇士》正因如此而在一些更偏右翼的边缘群体中大受欢迎。所以，有人可能会辩称这确实造成了危害——这很有意思，不是吗？既然我们已经聊到了《300勇士》以及关于我们如何看待特洛伊战争、现代社会如何看待特洛伊的种种话题，让我们多聊一点。一直以来令我着迷的一件事是，
that films as propaganda do harm, don't they? I mean, they enter into the collective imagination of people and if what they are promoting is, you know, difference, hatred, all this sort of stuff. Well, an interesting counterpoint would be 300, which is also a film about ancient Greece and tells the story of the Spartans at Thermopylae. Yeah.
蒙茅斯的杰弗里以及中世纪的一些英国和威尔士作家都对这样一个观点着迷：我们是特洛伊人的后代。曾经有一个名叫布鲁特斯（Brutus）的人，他是埃涅阿斯的亲戚，据说埃涅阿斯建立了罗马。而布鲁特斯带着一群特洛伊难民乘船跨越大海，建立了不列颠尼亚（Britannia），这个名字就是以他命名的。他将自己的王国分为三个部分：英格兰、苏格兰和威尔士，并把它们分给他的三个儿子。他还建立了一座名为“新特洛伊”的城市，后来这里变成了伦敦，诸如此类。
And that, I think, is a brilliant portrayal of the ancient world because it very accurately portrays the Spartans as proto-Nazis, as proto-fascists, which is basically what they were. The Spartans were a huge inspiration to the Nazis. And one of the things that's unsettling about 300 is that it doesn't serve up the kind of morality that we expect. The strong are strong, the weak are weak, and the weak are contemptible for being weak. And it's very unsettling, but I think also very, very accurate. But there's a reason, you know, 300 has become very popular with the kind of more right-wing fringes for that reason so uh it could be argued that that's done damage um that is interesting isn't it let's talk a bit about since you've
这到底是怎么回事？令我感到困惑的问题是：为什么人们会去共情作为失败者的特洛伊人，而不是作为胜利者的希腊人？因为特洛伊人最终才是赢家，因为你刚才提到的埃涅阿斯——他是阿佛洛狄忒的儿子、特洛伊诸王的堂亲——他逃出了特洛伊，据说他来到了意大利，他的后代建立了罗马。所以罗马人将自己等同于特洛伊人。因此，如果你将自己等同于特洛伊人，你其实也是在将自己等同于罗马人。那么罗马人当初为什么要这样做呢？为什么罗马人……是因为希腊人是他们的竞争对手，
we've got on to 300 and all this stuff about how we see the trojan war how modern societies have seen the trojan so something that's always fascinated me is the fact that um jeffrey of monmouth and sort of medieval you, English and Welsh writers were fascinated by this idea that we are descended from the Trojans. There was a fellow called Brutus who was related to Aeneas who supposedly founded Rome and that Brutus basically sails across the sea with a load of Trojan refugees and founds Britannia, which is named after him. And he separates his kingdom into three parts, England, Scotland and Wales, which he gives to his three sons. And he founds a city called New Troy, which becomes London and all this sort of
所以他们需要一个替代的起源故事吗？他们不能直接采用希腊的起源故事吗？因为特洛伊战争和荷马——荷马是备受尊崇的伟大诗 人，而你自然也想分一杯羹。如果你能把自己和那个故事联系起来，那么你实际上就是在参与其中。而且，这也为罗马人前去征服希腊提供了一种合乎情理的解释。没错。因为他们可以说他们是在为特洛伊人复仇。而且，攻陷君士坦丁堡的奥斯曼统治者穆罕默德二世也极力利用了这一点。
stuff. What's all that about? And the question that puzzles me is why would you empathise with the Trojans who are losers rather than the Greeks who are the winners? Because the Trojans are ultimately the winners because Aeneas who you mentioned who is the son of Aphrodite, cousin of the princes of Troy, he escapes Troy, supposedly he comes to Italy and his descendants found Rome. So the Romans identify themselves with the Trojans. So if you identify yourself with the Trojans, you're also identifying yourself with the Romans. So why did the Romans do it though? Why did the Romans, is it because the Greeks were their rivals
这到底是怎么回事？让我感到困惑的是，为什么你会去同情作为失败者的特洛伊人，而不是作为胜利者的希腊人呢？因为特洛伊人最终才是胜利者，正如你所提到的埃涅阿斯，他是阿芙罗狄蒂的儿子、特洛伊王子的表亲，他逃出了特洛伊，据传说他来到了意大利，他的后代建立了罗马。因此，罗马人将自己视为特洛伊人。所以，如果你把自己当作特洛伊人，也就是把自己当作罗马人。那么，罗马人为什么要这样做呢？为什么罗马人……是因为希腊人是他们的竞争对手
and they needed a sort of alternative origin story? They couldn't just take a Greek origin story. Because the Trojan War and Homer, you know, Homer is the prestige poet and you want a bit of it. And if you can identify yourself with that story, then you're kind of joining in with it. And also, it provides a rationale for the Romans to go and conquer Greece. Right. Because they can say that they're taking vengeance for the Trojans. And that's something that Mehmed II, the Ottoman who captures Constantinople, he makes great play with this as well.
并且他们需要某种替代的起源故事？他们不可能直接采用希腊的起源故事。因为特洛伊战争和荷马，你知道的，荷马是备受推崇的诗人，你也会想沾点光。如果你能让自己与那个故事产生联系，那么你就等于融入其中了。此外，这也为罗马人去征服希腊提供了一个合理的借口。没错。因为他们可以说他们是在为特洛伊人复仇。奥斯曼帝国征服君士坦丁堡的苏丹穆罕默德二世，也非常津津乐道于这一点。
He's saying that he is ruling as the heir of the Trojans, that by capturing Constantinople, he's taking vengeance for the sack of Troy. And do any modern Turks think this? I don't think so. Erdogan, he's the heir of Achilles, or the heir of, sorry, the heir of Hector. Mehmed II, his mother was Greek, so he was kind of plugged into that culture. think it's the era of achilles i think i mean sorry the era of hector um remember the second
他说他是作为特洛伊人的继承人进行统治，通过攻占君士坦丁堡，他是在为特洛伊的陷落复仇。会有现代土耳其人这样想吗？我不这么认为。埃尔多安，他是阿喀琉斯的继承人，或者是，抱歉，是赫克托耳的继承人。穆罕默德二世，他的母亲是希腊人，所以他某种程度上融入了那种文化。我认为这是阿喀琉斯的时代，我的意思是，抱歉，是赫克托耳的时代，呃，还记得第二个
his mother was greek so he he was kind of plugged into that culture he was he was aware of it i mean obviously it's much more of a a european thing but in the in the wake of the the collapse of of the roman empire in early medieval europe it's a way for um people as they start to get a sense of their own identity they look around and and by plugging yourself into um greek mythology roman history um you're giving yourself a kind of real sense of prestige and to say that you're descended from the trojans i mean that you know kind of multiplies it and the great thing about um about britannia and brutus coming to britain is that um britain was supposedly a land of giants. And I saw in the paper today that Boris Johnson was saying that he's now committed to having a
他的母亲是希腊人，所以他某种程度上融入了那种文化，他是了解这一点的，我的意思是，很显然这更多是一件欧洲的事情，但在早期中世纪欧洲罗马帝国崩溃之后，这是人们开始意识到自己身份时的一种方式，他们环顾四周，通过将自己融入希腊神话、罗马历史，你赋予了自己一种真实的声望感，说你是特洛伊人的后裔，我的意思是，这你知道，某种程度上成倍增加了这种感觉。关于不列颠和布鲁图斯来到不列颠，最棒的一点是，不列颠据说曾是一片巨人的土地。我今天在报纸上看到，鲍里斯·约翰逊说他现在致力于拥有一个
cabinet of giants. So Brutus supposedly fights two giants called Gorg and Magog. And it would be great to see them in the cabinet. Yeah, in place of Gavin Williamson or somebody. You don't think he's a Trojan figure? I think Gorg as Secretary of State for Education would be a lot more fun. But it's a funny thing, isn't it, how this question about who you empathise with. So when I was reading it to my son the other night, I said, who do you want to win?
巨人的内阁。所以布鲁图斯据说与两个名叫戈尔戈和马戈戈的巨人战斗。看到他们在内阁里会很棒。是的，代替加文·威廉姆森或某个人。你不认为他是一个特洛伊式的人物吗？我认为让戈尔戈担任教育大臣会更有趣。但这是一件很有趣的事，不是吗？关于你对谁产生共鸣这个问题。所以前几天晚上我读给我儿子听时，我问，你想让谁赢？
He knows the Trojans lose, because kind of everybody seems to just know that they lose. And he said, Oh, well, I really like the Trojans. I like Hector, I know it doesn't end well for him. But and I said, that's funny, because I liked Hector when I was, you know, eight, I he was, and I wonder whether we think differently than our predecessors might have done, because we are programmed, this is, you know, this is a gift to you with your Christianity, whether we are programmed to cheer for the underdog. We know the Trojans lose. So we kind of, you know, we think they're the good guys. And the Greeks who behave so badly, squabbling about slave girls and crying and behaving in this sort of ludicrous,
他知道特洛伊人输了，因为似乎每个人都知道他们输了。他说，哦，好吧，我真的很喜欢特洛伊人。我喜欢赫克托耳，我知道他的结局不太好。但是，我说，这很有趣，因为当我八岁的时候我也喜欢赫克托耳，我不知道我们的想法是否会与我们的前辈不同，因为我们被程序化了——这是你借基督教送给你的礼物——我们是否被程序化为去为弱者加油。我们知道特洛伊人输了。所以我们某种程度上，你知道，我们认为他们是好人。而希腊人表现得如此糟糕，为奴隶女孩争吵不休，哭哭啼啼，表现出这种荒谬的、
sort of whingy, snowflakey way. Who empathises with them now? Well, Achilles is the great hero. He is, you could say, hungry like the wolf. Very good talk, Thomas. So we pledge that we get a new romantic lyric in every week and they're back at the net there, I like to think. Oh, did the talent in the TV work up that one? and then back of the net there. Oh, I did a talent of a TV. Well, I've got that one. So Achilles is the great hero.
发牢骚的、脆弱的方式。现在谁会与他们产生共鸣呢？嗯，阿喀琉斯是伟大的英雄。可以说，他就像饿狼一样渴望。讲得很好，托马斯。所以我们保证每周都能听到一首新的浪漫抒情诗，我喜欢想象他们又回到了网前。哦，电视里的天才们想出了那个吗？然后又回到了网前。哦，我做了一个电视天才。好吧，我记住了。所以阿喀琉斯是伟大的英雄。
And he's a great hero because he's basically the best at killing people. And that does seem frightening to us, I think. I mean, Achilles is a frightening figure. But you're right. You mentioned Alexander. Alexander completely models himself on Achilles. And Alexander kills a lot of people as well. And I think you're right. I think it is essentially... He's got a view to a kill, Tom. He's got a view
他是一个伟大的英雄，因为他基本上最擅长杀人。这在我们看来确实很吓人，我想。我的意思是，阿喀琉斯是一个可怕的人物。但你是对的。你提到了亚历山大。亚历山大完全以阿喀琉斯为榜样。亚历山大也杀了很多人。我想你是对的。我认为这本质上是……他有一种杀戮的视角，汤姆。他有一种
to a kill. I think that our sensibilities are incredibly Christian now. And so we are kind of programmed to identify with those who suffer, those who are the victims, those who become the slaves rather than those who do the slaving. But the initial consumers of the Iliad, the people who listen to the poets tell and retell these stories, they presumably wouldn't have thought that. They'd have just thought these people are losers, therefore, you know, they got what was coming to them. Some did, but some didn't. So again, this is a massive theme in Greek tragedy, is the suffering of the losers. And in a way, one of the bleakest works of literature ever written is Euripides' Trojan Women, which he's writing against the backdrop of the Peloponnesian War, the great war between Athens and Sparta, which will actually end with the defeat of Athens. But the Athenians are sacking a lot of cities as the Trojans do. And Euripides gives this portrayal of the queens and the princesses of Troy being rounded up after the sack of the city, about to be led off into slavery. And it's a devastating portrait of what it means to be a victim in a war. And the power of it is precisely that there is no real kind of
杀戮的视角。我认为我们现在的敏感度带有极强的基督教色彩。所以我们某种程度上被程序化去认同那些受苦的人、那些受害者、那些沦为奴隶的人，而不是那些奴役他人的人。但《伊利亚特》最初的消费者，那些听诗人们反复讲述这些故事的人，他们大概不会这么想。他们只会认为这些人是失败者，所以，你知道，他们咎由自取。有些人是这么想的，但有些人不是。所以同样地，这是希腊悲剧中的一个巨大主题，那就是失败者的痛苦。在某种程度上，有史以来最凄凉的文学作品之一就是欧里庇得斯的《特洛伊妇女》，他是在伯罗奔尼撒战争（雅典和斯巴达之间的大战，最终以雅典战败告终）的背景下创作这部作品的。但雅典人像特洛伊人一样洗劫了许多城市。欧里庇得斯刻画了特洛伊的女王和公主们在城市洗劫后被驱赶、即将被带去当奴隶的情景。这是一幅关于战争中成为受害者的意义的毁灭性画卷，其力量恰恰在于其中没有任何真正的
redemptive quality to it. The key thing that you get from Christianity is the idea that there is a redemptive quality in suffering. So if you counterpoint the sack of Troy in Greek myth to the sack of Jerusalem in the Old Testament, it's terrible. It's devastating. But the conviction that the Jews hold to is that ultimately it's expressive of God's power. And so therefore it is, you know, there is a purpose to it. What you get in Euripides is absolutely bled of any sense of that. This is just, you you know terrible stuff happens yeah and so and so it was that kind of euripidean take was resurrected an awful lot during the um uh the the gulf war and the aftermath so it was almost
救赎性质。你从基督教中获得的核心理念是，痛苦中存在着一种救赎性质。因此，如果你把希腊神话中特洛伊的洗劫与旧约中耶路撒冷的洗劫进行对比，那是可怕的。这是毁灭性的。但犹太人坚信，这最终表达了上帝的力量。因此，你知道，这是有目的的。你在欧里庇得斯的作品中完全看不到这种感觉。这只是，你知道，可怕的事情发生了，是的。因此，欧里庇得斯式的这种视角在海湾战争及其余波期间被大量复活，所以几乎
impossible to go to a theater and not see a greek tragedy in which um the greeks were the you know the coalition forces and yeah well as is traditional um we end the podcast with a 10-minute lecture from tom about uh christianity's um how it's changed the modern world and how everybody should go about his book which i'm sure you already have um i think we've pretty much run out of time tom um but i think there's enough in this for us to come back to troy and the trojan War later on in the series, depending on how long the series runs, because there's tons of questions that we actually didn't get to. And I am so sorry to all those people, but we will get to your question one day, possibly.
不可能不去剧院看一场希腊悲剧，在剧中希腊人就是你知道的联军，是的，按照传统，我们以汤姆关于基督教如何改变现代世界以及每个人都应该去读他的书（我相信你们已经读过了）的十分钟演讲来结束播客。汤姆，我想我们的时间差不多用完了，但我认为这里的内容足够我们在节目后续再回来探讨特洛伊和特洛伊战争，这取决于节目会播多久，因为实际上还有很多问题我们没有涉及。我非常向广大听众道歉，但总有一天我们会解答你们的问题，也许吧。
So we'll be back next week with more meanderings down the lanes of history. Please subscribe, rate and review, but obviously only if you like us. It does make all the difference. And please do get in touch with us on Twitter. We are at TheRestHistory, so no is. Or you can also use at Holland underscore Tom or at DC Sandbrook. And that's it. Goodbye for now. Thanks for listening.
所以我们下周将带着更多在历史小径上的漫步回归。请订阅、评分和评论，当然，前提是你喜欢我们。这确实意义重大。请务必在推特上与我们联系。我们的账号是TheRestHistory，没有空格。或者你也可以使用@Holland_underscore_Tom或@DCSandbrook。就是这样。暂时再见。谢谢收听。
Thanks a lot. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听加长单集、抢先收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。